est-ce que ça a été ma fierté c'est quoi
c'est que ce thème est une icône aussi
elle est quasiment pas de français quoi
donc je me suis dit les gens savent pas
que je suis connue ne savent pas que je
suis riche que je suis une sommité
locale tu t'es quand je bouffe et les
couilles
je me suis dit 48 ans j'ai fait battre
de l aile mais ça tombait
mais j'ai dit
je
[Rires]
fais un berlinois way un chien lors
[Applaudissements]
de trois ans tu vois c'est vrai quoi les
gens ne te connaissais pas il n'y a pas
de français quand c'est vrai alors en
revanche qui m'a déçu je suis pas connu
à l'étranger non à bassens et
déjà qu'en france ça n'est pas non mais
c'est vrai alors bonne vacances odieuses
mais je suis franchement le jeu d'abord
c'est un des plus beaux mykonos c'était
les paysages
annoncé mais la végétation luxuriante
est ce que votre attitude maintenant
mais j'ai désiré que le soir j'ai
parfois j'ai dû très gentiment faire des
sauts à regrouper parce qu'on a droit à
ce que n'a jamais tellement je ne peux
pas sur dix jours on a des jeunes
toreros iucn
vous mettez dans leur
[Applaudissements]
sillage le strudel non
il suffit maintenant que tu as un scoop
it out je me demande même genre ni me
faire rembourser j'ai payé mon demi
d'hôtels jeunes hormis un soir de match
alors c'est pas vrai un soir couasnon
jour là mais la chambre où tu parlais ou
balles dans les jambes de d'autres
personnes mais comment ça j'ai été
véhiculé j'étais bien qu laisse deviner
alors je garde juste après
cette tournée qui va regarder ou se
lever
ces véhicules et et voilà parfois il les
gens un petit peu plus jeune qui a un
peu moins d'argent ça et moi j'avais
j'avais loué une moto un peu la tom
krause
voit la nature de tom cruise bien formés
très bas mais que lorsque génial c'est
que tu apportes dans le permis n'a pas
besoin de cash
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tant qu'il
n'y a pas de police et une voiture de
police m'a reconduit sans calorie va
bien mais le situent eux mêmes c'est la
seule police qui
culmine à l'ailé j'ai eu un flic quoi
thériault l'emploi implique alors bel
matraque
affi grec doit être ça aussi ça plaît
quiros
il est arrêté parce que j'avais pas de
casque et moi je parle pas grecque alors
ça part un peu en anglais on rigole et
n'agira ouais il y aura des ouïes
boatiful ou non il me dit elle mais elle
met allemagne à 4 km h
30 et en tunisie
alors oui donc et donc voilà et puis on
a discuté un petit budget j'ai pas mis
deux cas c'est vrai cgt en faute et donc
j'ai là il m'a dit j'ai pas eu de casse
mais j'ai pas non plus mythiques non
valides et qu'est-ce qu'il faut alors
que soient punis non
je fais le pic mais to be punished elle
met à l'admettre elle met gds ailleurs
le canada dans l'âme
il m'a dit je gagne comme ça wiseid m
j'ai dit je t'aime moi non au 4 juin
[Applaudissements]
d'accord c'était bouder
passionnant j'en reconnais pas gratuit
alors qu n'est pas du côté grec mais on
l'appelait alors j'ai des attentes très
vite
j'ai
dit aux adhérentes mais to be punished
ouais mais tombait boni
la grâce est vrai il était jeune de
a-rod 126 127 on sait pas mais il m'a
dit yes men est tout à fait tu as fait
ta non
[Applaudissements]
j'ai des traces de revient n'est pas
très grand mais comme tu dis quelque
chose et j'ai rencontré le maire le
maire de mykonos absolument et alors et
lui est cool il est très sympa de je
connaissais rebond s'était déjà vu une
fois mais non c'est vraiment parler dans
ce marais lahccen non j'ai beaucoup joué
mais non pas du tout non je crois pas qu
assez bizarrement le maire n'est pas gay
dominique busso et samatan je veux dire
c'est eu pas mal
mais c'est vrai tu peur et sans rien et
tu peux avoir des chaussures de ski et
un d'abandonner ses malmédy bien que non
non c'est pas vrai que vous avez annoncé
que vous allez venir je me lève et je
lui dis mais vous découvrez coquet
noonan tient pas ses promesses
je vais la tenir pour toi
tu avais promis quelque chose
non c'est vrai nom mais je connais le
maire de mykonos comment s appelle quand
il s'appelle dominique bussereau
37 ans domine toujours mais non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit là quand même c'est quand
même le comble non c'est vrai de
dominique plus sommaire de biens merlot
non mais sans déconner c'est comme si
c'était moi célibataire il a pas
quelqu'un dans sa vie avant il a souvent
quelle période
non car dans ta vie mais non il n'est
plus en couple bah
merde nous amène à fond non mais je
mords parce que quand même parce que là
tu as quand même fait quelques
révélations
min si je suis avec quelqu'un qui a été
je dirais extrêmement compensatoire des
principes actifs
si patrick éteignez la lumière non
mais comment je l'appelle interrupteur
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est fou ce
way we habillée comme ça dit ferme les
yeux non
mais c'est quoi ces mots après si ça
n'est pas libre et non ça se passe il
alors non mais alors là ça coupe le
libre je suis d'ailleurs un couple au
lit voilà vous abonner à bien certaines
ibra oui super visionner pas du tout non
pas que toi aussi tu te super visionner
ça c'est un peu juste par tous
points de vue webb a bien sûr bah tu vas
voir tu as posé les bonnes vacances
s'est passé les superbes entre l'un et
figure toi que ce sera ma dernière info
et je vous laisse le
juge
aurait raconté les règles parce que j'ai
hâte d'entendre mais moi j'ai peur
d'attaquer 3,6 là où enfin et le maire
m'a demandé aux prochaines élections
municipales d'être sur la liste non gt3
de mykonos voyageurs alors on s'en fout
indépendant quel message
rajoutez y voilà si gignac mais ça peut
faire des élèves tout ça ma thèse quand
même toit les temps parce que la
politique tu as vu chez impliqué thème
la dernière allait bien
mais quelle serait ta première mesure
pour mykonos alors moines femmes sur
l'île parce que
[Applaudissements]
vous avez les bourses vous avez lesbos
avec beaucoup de femmes et ça prend
beaucoup de place à valladolid
vidéo vous excite je prends mille
habitants à l'année et 400 milles était
à peu près 150 mille femmes et je
reconnais que c'était beaucoup
de sang min font là-bas ni même les
loisirs local et loisirs locaux et où tu
vois pas là bas que pour eux
très belles plages
mais c'est vrai qu'après là bas c'est
vrai que tu vas - cueillir sur pied des
coquillages punch et a fait du mal cyril
non non non mais jaune pour la mykonos
et pour le moment ma on a une belle
route afférents ça pour l'instant voilà
on reste chacun chez soi il est bien